[Musique]
au coeur de l'europe le pays des trois
frontières un territoire où se
rencontrent la france la suisse et
l'allemagne autour de la ville de bâle
le secteur est un véritable poids lourd
de l'économie européenne et connaît un
important développement
côté français à saint louis se construit
l'un des plus grands projets
d'aménagement d'alsace c'est un projet
effectivement de grande envergure sur le
territoire du sud alsace
un projet qui a été initié il ya
quelques années par la communauté de
communes des trois frontières et qui
aujourd'hui est portée bien sûr par cinq
gars de l'eau aux liens étroits bien sûr
avec le conseil départemental qui est
membre du syndicat mixte d'aménagement
du texte un port qui pète je dirais la
gestion de ce grand projet euro 3 lys
est constitué de deux zones
d'aménagement à proximité immédiate de
l'euroairport le quartier à l'ouest de
la gare et l'une d'elles est dans ce
quartier donc nous aurons des activités
de haute technologie avec un campus avec
la recherche et développement et l'autre
quartier se situe de l'autre côté de la
de la rd 105 en bordure de l'autoroute
entre la fin de ce1 lui et l'aéroport de
bâle mulhouse 1 et sur ce pôle nous
trouverons des activités commerciales
bien sûr et puis tout un parc paysager
un parc de loisirs mais aussi gérait des
entreprises innovantes qui feront qui
seront complémentaires à celles que nous
trouvons sur le quartier des lices point
de départ du projet heureux trois listes
tirer parti de la locomotive économique
bâloise
d'autant que la grande ville suisse
manque aujourd'hui de l'espace pour
s'étendre
une aubaine pour les villes frontalières
qui pourrait bien voir de nouvelles
entreprises s'installer chez elle
la vocation de ce projet est bien sûr
d'attirer de nouvelles compétences de
nouveaux talents sur notre territoire
pour participer bien sûr à
l'attractivité de cette agglomération
trinational de bâle je rappelle que nous
sommes quand même à la croisée
delà de la suisse et de l'allemagne sur
un secteur effectivement dans le pib est
un des plus forts non seulement d'europe
mais aussi au niveau mondial et quelque
part nous souhaitons profiter davantage
de cette croissance et participer à ce
développement
au coeur du projet euro 3 lys la
question des mobilités
ici se croisent autoroutes voies ferrées
et aéroports certains axes sont d'ores
et déjà saturé c'est le cas de la route
départementale 105 en prévision du
nouveau quartier cette dernière va être
requalifié ses accès à l'autoroute sur
modifier sur ce volet là il est vrai que
le conseil départemental a un rôle
majeur à jouer puisqu'il est chargé
depuis deux ans d'ailleurs ils
travaillent sur ce projet de
réaménagement effectivement de la
bretelle d'accès de sortie de
l'autoroute mais aussi de la nouvelle de
la requalification de cette route
départementale qui est vraiment au coeur
de ce nouveau projet r3 les seins une
consultation publique vient d'être lancé
au sujet de la rd 105 pour donner son
avis rendez vous sur le site du conseil
départemental du jour
autre mode de transport au coeur des
transformations de la ville de
saint-louis le tram
depuis décembre la ligne 3 relie la gare
à la ville de bâle ce quartier se veut
une véritable plateforme multimodale des
transports et le tram 3 c'est vrai que
nous avons inauguré la nouvelle
extension et le franchissement la douane
suisse vers la gare de st louis au mois
de décembre le département il ya pris sa
part également puisqu'il accompagner
financièrement ce projet donc l'idée
c'est vraiment d'amener la population
par sept par cette nouvelle voie j'irai
de transports doux en tout cas
transports publics vers la gare mais
après de le prolonger en fait jusque
jusqu'au coeur de la zone nouvelles
zones d'activités et ce projet-là verra
le jour
effectivement quand le projet sera plus
sera plus avancé au niveau de l'agglo le
projet implique de nombreux partenaires
agglomération communes conseil
départemental états mais aussi les
voisins suisses et allemands et c'est
vrai que tout géré toutes les
collectivités ici participe pas depuis
très longtemps au bon fonctionnement de
cette coopération et chacun y apporte sa
pierre à la fois les collectivités
locales les communes mais aussi
l'eurodistrict trinational de bâle
le département est très engagé un très
impliqué dans cette coopération
transfrontalière c'est vrai que le dés
qu'il s'agit d'aménagements aux
frontières on sait bien que ça dépasse
largement l'impact de ces de ces
aménagements dépasse largement géré le
territoire local national
les porteurs du projet espèrent pouvoir
démarrer les travaux d'ici 2020 nombre d
aspects des futurs quartiers restent
encore à définir mais tous souhaitent
que ces derniers participent au
renouveau du territoire tout en
s'intégrant à l'existant il va falloir
trouver un bon équilibre et s'associe
gérait un des enjeux de ce projet un bon
équilibre entre l'habitat entre la
croissance économique la croissance de
l'emploi mais aussi je dirais
tout ce qui concerne la préservation et
la protection de l'environnement pour
faire vraiment en sorte que voilà jir le
territoire des trois frontières restent
en harmonie avec l'existant se projette
dans le futur mais toujours avec des
valeurs environnementales très forte
pour que la qualité de vie géré de la
population reste un objectif prioritaire
pour vous tenir informés de l'avancée du
projet rendez vous sur www.eurostar.com
r